ouh
là aujourd'hui on est speed je vais vous
parler de l'hyper vitesse
ce terme désigne une très grande vitesse
approximativement 11 mille kilomètres
par heure à ce stade on ne compte
d'ailleurs plus en kilomètres par heure
mais en mac et onze mille kilomètres par
heure ça correspond à mach 8,8 pour vous
donner une idée mach 1 c'est la vitesse
du son 1224 kilomètres par heure les
météorites qui atteignent la terre les
rentrées de capsules depuis l'espace se
font à l'hyper vitesse et c'est
également la vitesse à laquelle se
déplacent buzz l'éclair le célèbre
ranger de l'espace pour le voir à
l'oeuvre pourrait vite au cinéma il
arrive sur les écrans une année entière
de travail pour 4 minutes de vol à peine
croyable je suis poursuivi par le le
plus monstrueux des robots buzz
les clés
bonne chance
[Musique]
aussi l'éclair le 22 juin au cinéma